ladies and gentlemen of the reject
Nation this is big Ezra Miller is still
the flash I have five pictured can't
believe it the whole DC you're not
hinges on him oh wait no wrong celebrity
wrong celebrity my bad Jonathan Majors
this is Major news just found out I was
shooting a movie reaction and then I had
a whole bunch of text messages about it
he got dropped by his talent manager and
his PR team following the assault
charges this is pretty much like the
next step after that like he still has
his agency who's uh what I'm surprised
they're sticking with him for how much
longer to me it just seems like it's
only a matter of time now before he's
officially going to be replaced as king
the Conqueror we've already been hearing
talks for the past like at least a week
now there's scoopers like Jeff Snyder
going out there saying that Marvel has
already been having meetings with
Jonathan Majors as agent about potential
ways to move forward who they can be
potentially looking at for who they can
replace Jonathan Majors with and I feel
like you can replace King the conquer I
do and because as great of a performer
as he is for King the Conqueror at the
end of the day they have opened up the
Multiverse they have open up variants
they've done it all yeah so they could
totally get a different face on there
yeah they can but to me this is more
than enough to have me go down the road
at least saying yeah this guy's on his
way out because especially with like a
PR team I was talking with Michael
Tessler who's a lot more familiar with
this sort of area when it comes to like
the public relations department a PR
team they're they're they have
celebrities and they're used to dealing
with all kinds of
yeah situations like this are part of
their job and then you know following
the whole thing with what first came out
regarding these assault accusations and
charges the allegations and whatnot and
then following the the backlash of the
statement that was released by the
lawyer the text messages released that
just did not help him out and then this
has been silent it's just been quiet on
their end ever since it's been really
quiet they must know a little bit more
they have to know a lot more than what
we all know and for this to be the thing
where they are dropping and they're
firing them from the from as a client
right yeah to me this is just
confirmation that he's on his way out
yeah because I don't know like if
anybody is privy to the inside
information about the truth of what
really happened I mean you know agencies
managers they don't take precedence over
like legal counsel blah blah but you
know they're high on the list and they
have to have enough Intel to base this
decision on in the first place so I mean
yeah it's like if he had real concrete
evidence that he was innocent I feel
like they would just stay silent and and
wait for the court proceedings to take
place yeah this seems like a pretty loud
message and this is only this is like
the day this is being announced so his
agency could drop him at any moment you
know in the future here maybe by the
time this is uploaded absolutely because
sometimes you you get on these news
stories you wait like we've already like
kind of avoided some other things that
have come out before saying anything but
to me there's a reason all these
messages are coming in because it's
pretty much
here's what comes next after that this
is the next step down yeah he's already
got all this stuff for Loki season two
films I don't know if you know
replacement or whatever is going to lead
to a delay one of the alarm Bells going
off in my head about why they just
haven't gone ahead and done it is
because they had that whole James Gunn
situation where he was getting canceled
over some stuff tweets though not jokes
not quite the same but yeah they fired
him and then they eventually just
rehired him the court case has yet to
unfold they've still got a few weeks
until that's all done I mean I could go
for a while but still got a few weeks
until it begins yeah so I imagine that
Marvel or a five year company everyone
at Disney is probably like maybe we can
just like be quiet for a while and then
just wait it out and then see how it all
goes and then maybe by then you know
depending if Jonathan Majors gets gets
away with it and and then Loki comes out
and Everyone likes him again
just go through just power through just
lock it up and then at the very end say
see we had your back the entire time
nothing to worry about as much as I
joked about the Ezra Miller thing at the
top of this it is a different situation
to me like to me I still feel like that
Ezra Miller has to be addressed I
think that has to be talked about the
same way I'm going to watch Loki season
two and be like you know there's
Jonathan Majors anyway I watched Cree
three because I'm like yeah it's already
gone to flash like already done bunch of
people worked on it and whatever I still
feel like you got to talk about the Ezra
Miller thing this is about him not
continuing in other projects that have
yet to be filmed yeah right he's already
Inked to be a huge part like I don't
think they're gonna go out of their way
I'd be really surprised I have the
technology to do it but I would be very
shocked if they actually go well we
gotta reshoot all his scenes now from
Loki season two I I just don't see them
doing that at most I could see them
going into like the the you know
spoilers for anybody who cares for
Quantum Mania three two one but the
Council of Kings you could you know CG
various other faces just to bolster the
idea idea that variants don't all have
to have the same face but I think we've
seen through Loki and Spider-Man no way
home especially yeah variants can have
as many faces and and species types as
you want so I think while it seems like
a really big thing to get past right now
I don't think it would be as hard
especially if you find a talent who is
just as electric and who can Captivate
people I think then the conversation
will shift to like wow thank God they
found whoever you know steps up because
this is a huge star making moment for
them hope they keep their together
I haven't looked up who though the
girlfriend is I don't know if that
information is that information I don't
even know if it's out of who I would
hope not honestly I would hope not as
well you know if these charges are going
the way that they have been going making
it seem like yeah there's evidence that
he really did do what he is being
accused of doing I mean this poor woman
is suffering right now as well because
when you even when you look we did a
whole video about it I mean when looking
at those texts like one way to interpret
that someone in a very you know trauma
bonding type of toxic abusive
relationship right again it is just
allocation still at this even at this
point it's still just allegations right
at the same time like man yeah I know
we're all the focus is on the celebrity
the star here but whoever this woman is
my God this but this is such a shitty
ass situation to be well yeah I feel for
her almost no matter what because unless
it is that one in a billion situation
where she is just a conniving you know
uh uh you know story weaving person any
version of this is really kind of tragic
whether she is as they have reported in
some kind of emotional crisis whether it
was actually just the black and white he
assault like anything in between like
all of that is really harsh and ugly and
the one thing that this all makes me
wonder is they came out so gung-ho and
they're like we have this video we have
this evidence look at this and the text
message could have been maybe like a
test balloon honestly because what I
wonder is if the video or whatever they
have maybe doesn't fully exoner like
maybe it's just a bad situation where
two people are both kind of in a state
of 10 heat and anguish and maybe the
thing just isn't black and white to the
point that you can just say oh yeah he's
innocent and it's fine you know but John
listen they have already delayed my
Marvel projects enough as it is and as a
fan
I really just want them to get back on
track with the MCU and you know that's
fair get to Secret Wars I don't know
what I was thinking the Conqueror again
we're already getting like five less
Marvel movies a year like we can't
afford to wait anymore that matters that
matters more the Disney Monopoly must
continue sure so I have some picks for
who you can replace Jonathan Majors with
oh yeah these are good picks guys good
let's do it Glenn Howerton oh sure yeah
yeah I think he's hot right now Miles
Teller another hot one great one pretty
much anyone from Top Gun Maverick dude
just get Robert Downey Jr to replace it
Robert Downey I'm sure there's some
comic book that could explain it away
for me definitely what if some people
think that's racist like oh getting a
white guy
whatever racism
oh dude and he's due for a Redemption
comeback story like how perfect would
that be especially after steel I really
love Wanda Sykes I think he is hilarious
and can't get you a little bit more
comedy I feel like he's a little bit too
serious in Quantum don't joke I 100
approve that a casting choice I will
I'll watch Wanda Sykes Kang all day but
Regina Hulk play Kang as much as we're
messing around actually yeah yeah
it's a Watchman yeah that's Regina King
yeah yeah but no I mean and all in all
seriousness like this is a real serious
situation here for everyone involved but
I mean to me like it's a lot seems to be
pointing towards he did it
and so I I just hope whoever this woman
is that she's okay right now because
this is a terrifying situation to be in
a soul-consuming situation to be in oh
you hope she's okay Marvel will be fine
guys yep that's the least this should be
at least you will be okay they'll figure
it out and it will it will be fine in
fact more people will watch that movie
regardless because of you know seeing
how they adjust to the situation and if
he is innocent if he is innocent then I
hope that we are able to move past it if
if he is yeah okay that's all he can
really hope for is just we gotta wait
see how it plays out I'm just like well
that was freaking surprising like it's
actually I thought all this would be put
to a halt until the the trial or
whatever it was done that's that's when
I thought we would start getting this
information
um but now now is
that's not inspiring it's a big alarm
Bell well what do you guys think
uh do you think that this is uh leaning
in the direction of him actually getting
fired leave your thoughts down below
let's end on a funny note
foreign